foreign
just announced a whole human-sized human
shaped
sentient robot this is not a drill this
is a thing that really just happened and
a lot of things come to mind when
hearing that so let's get into it now
the two things that might have come to
your mind when hearing that like me are
number one why Tesla of all companies
and number two why a robot human of all
things
but if you frame it a certain way it
actually can make a lot of sense but you
got to break a few things down first to
get there so let's get there so Tesla
Tesla is a car company mostly you know
I've reviewed their cars we've seen
their announcements their factories
maybe we'll call it a vehicle company
they have a truck they have a bunch of
other stuff but they have a factory that
makes cars so they're a car company but
only like by that specific definition
it's actually pretty common to look at
Tesla as a software company uh just
because they're software advantage and
all the things that they do with the
software on their cars is so important
to them it's like they're a software
company that happens to make electric
cars and so when you compare to the
Mercedes of the world or the Audis of
the world or BMWs I would never describe
those companies as software companies
but for Tesla that's where their main
advantage is and so part of this
software thing that they're doing is
this self-driving project okay now aside
from all the masses of missed time
windows and over optimistic promises and
deadlines and things like that their
self-driving is currently as it is today
some of the most advanced in the world
and it's not because of high resolution
mapping or predetermined routes it's
because Teslas are using their sensors
and or mostly cameras at this point and
constantly scanning their environments
and making thousands of little on the
Fly decisions in real time and then all
of the miles driven with this autopilot
in action is used to upload the data
back to their servers and train the
whole rest of the fleet so it's this
whole this whole system is a constantly
self-improving thing the bigger it gets
the faster it can continue to get better
so this requires a lot of computing a
lot of horsepower to be frank and a lot
of smart code and that's what Tesla's
been really good at so Tesla had their
AI day a couple days ago you might not
have heard about it but they do this
every year they live stream a bunch of
talks from Tesla Engineers about
computer vision and how their neural
networks have evolved over time and
explaining their focus on making
autonomous cars that rely on computer
vision and their synthetic visual cortex
it's really great lots of informative
complex stuff and at this year's they
unveiled their new custom D1 chip which
is this chip that's designed and built
entirely in-house by a car company which
is specifically made to train Tesla's
full self-driving algorithms based on
driving footage even faster and they're
basically going to be replacing all of
their gpus they're currently using to
make this super computer designed to do
computer vision machine learning it's
big stuff and so at some point during
all of this elon's on stage talking and
he says something about to the effect of
Tesla is basically a robotics company uh
Tesla is arguably the world's biggest
robotics company because our cars are
like semi-sentient robots on Wheels and
if you think about it
it's like okay yeah I could I could see
that I mean obviously Tesla Tesla builds
cars so we'll call them a car company
still but like if it's Tesla's AI day
and they're giving a presentation and
they're trying to make as good of a show
as possible for recruiting purposes
they're going to call it robots so they
happen to make robots that are on Wheels
but yeah that's that's how you can get
it to make sense mentally it's like all
right yeah self-driving cars is just one
application of AI and computer vision
and Robotics just to just to solve that
problem so that's what's happening it's
a bunch of sensors scanning its
environment making a bunch of decisions
based on that and then training future
versions of it based on what happens
that's just what's happening in
self-driving cars so that I can see
making sense then Elon right afterward
said this uh it kind of makes sense to
put that onto a humanoid form he says it
makes sense to make these robots in
humanoid form
and that is where I disagree so this is
the newly unveiled Tesla robot it's
called Tesla bot it's a five foot eight
125 pound Sleek looking like black and
white human shaped robot with this face
mask with a screen on it it's got hands
with you know full 10 fingers it's got
feet but with no toes it's pretty slow
it has a max speed of 5 miles per hour
so that you can outrun it and then it
can lift things up up to 10 pounds with
the arms extended or it can deadlift 150
lots of cameras and actuators and of
course the full self-driving computer
inside so they're saying it's going to
be easy to overpower or run away from so
that should never be a concern
uh but the main purpose the purpose of
this Tesla bot the thing that they kept
saying over and over again on stage
during a presentation and during Q as
when they're asked about it they kept
defaulting to it will be able to do
tasks that are repetitive dangerous or
boring so that humans don't have to and
so if you buy if you buy Tesla as a
robotics company then
yeah this makes sense it's just another
robot that will use the sensors to scan
its environment and make a bunch of
decisions and navigate around this world
that it's in
but the thing that I have to say and
this is going to come with the caveat
that I'm of course not a robotics
engineer I'm not an expert at this but
here's my take
the human form
is very inefficient now don't get me
wrong humans were pretty great right
we're very accomplished species
um and we're very complex and we've done
a lot of things well but they work as a
body so well because number one our
brains are amazing but number two
because we've built this world around us
that we live in mostly with ergonomics
designed for humans
but when it's not designed for humans
like this upright bipedal thing that's
balancing all the time it's not very
efficient we just did a retro Tech
episode about this about humanoid robots
so I'll link it below if you haven't
already watched it it's it's a super fun
one but we did a lot of talking with
people and experts about this
and it turns out if you want to make a
robot to take over a task
you typically don't want to build it
like a human you want to build it for a
single task and make it as efficient as
possible at that one task so pop culture
forever has been obsessed with humanoid
robots like I can't even count all the
instances of humanoid shaped robots in
movies and TV shows over the years that
we found it's something we've been
fascinated with since the beginning of
time there's endless versions of it but
it turns out the ideal way to make a
robot vacuum the floor for you is not to
build a human sized shaped robot that
pushes around a vacuum it's to make the
robot the vacuum the vacuum is the robot
you don't want a humanoid robot standing
at the sink washing dishes for you the
dishwasher is the robot like that's the
single purpose-built robot Tesla knows
this you don't have a humanoid shaped
robot sitting in your car driving the
car for you the car is the robot the
self-driving car that drives itself has
already been done so the list of things
you would want a human-shaped robot for
is pretty small because labor is
typically not designed around the human
form the one example they kept giving
over and over in their AI Day
presentation it was grocery shopping so
they you know
you walk to the grocery store you grab a
cart or a basket and you pick out some
items and put them in the basket I guess
that's you know you need a bunch of
different peripherals and things to pull
that off and maybe a human-shaped robot
would be fine for that
but there's not a whole lot else I can
think of like even when I picture the
most simple boring tasks like making a
bed or building a table like when I
picture a robot that would be especially
good at that I don't picture a
human-shaped one I picture one that's
super focused and super efficient maybe
I'm just short-sighted but I remember
when I talked with Elon at the factory a
couple years ago about all the things
that they do with robots versus the
couple of things left that they still do
with humans he had a really interesting
answer so some parts of it are
like 80 to 90 automated and then some
parts of it are like uh only 10 to 20
what are those what are those parts that
humans do better than humans are really
good at adaptation
um and and Rapid Evolution and like
doing like little like finicky things
like like that
um it's like electronic connect uh a
hose that's like sort of dangling around
I see and and then you get like the
robots like gonna find the hose grab it
like then connect it to another hose at
that point it's like really hard yeah
like a person can just go oh they're
done gotcha yeah that makes a lot of
sense yeah and it's like when you see it
it's like wow it's super super obvious
right and then we try to have robots do
this it's like robots like grabbing the
wrong thing and like trying to stick it
over here and it's like oh the the hose
was here when the robot throw was here
and Matt like tries to grab air and then
like smashes into the car it's like you
don't want that we yeah it was the
community bearers uh tragedy of Errors
so yeah all that all that really made me
think like with as good as Tesla is with
self-driving
why would you want a humanoid a
human-shaped robot to try to do things
that humans are already good at how long
is it going to take for that robot to
actually get good at things that humans
are good at and you know what the best
way to answer that would probably be to
look at the most advanced robotics
company that I can think of at the
moment which is Boston Dynamics so
there's like there's two very different
uh types of humanoid robots that I've
seen exist in this world
on one end it's like the dumb single
purpose thing you see at CES like these
are the barely functional robots you see
that can really do only a few things
decently well they're kind of cheesy
looking they're human shaped for no
reason but they exist and then on the
other end of the spectrum there's Boston
Dynamics Atlas and man I wish when I was
out there I could have seen Atlas in
person because just the dog spot is
already impressive enough like it's got
the sensors it has a basic level of
understanding scanning its environment
and it can be programmed to do dangerous
or boring or repetitive things and go
places that humans wouldn't go and we
say dog because they've called it spot
and it's kind of looks like a dog if you
make it behave the right way sometimes
but really it's just a quadruped any
four-legged animal would do but Atlas on
the other hand well well I haven't
necessarily seen it do anything
specifically useful yet but seeing that
five foot human shaped robot navigate
the world in crazy ways is something
else I mean I did share a new video of
it uh doing parkour and Elon seemed very
impressed but even after all these years
of development and the history of how
much we've seen it get better Atlas is
not a robot that's going to be on sale
for people to buy anytime soon and if
you ask them about it they'll tell you
it's just them experimenting with their
Computing in a new form factor and so at
the end of the day my take
Tesla bot probably won't exist anytime
soon either you know I know they said on
stage there would be a prototype maybe
next year I uh I kind of doubt that
they're gonna LeapFrog Boston Dynamics
in the next two years but then here's
the other thing even if they do come out
with it Tesla right now is training
their self-driving computers with
billions and billions of miles of
self-driving happening on the streets
today right so the best way to get as
much data about that as possible is to
have it go out in the real world and do
it it's kind of Genius actually that
they're making so many cars and people
are really using it for them but now
they're going to be asking for a
humanoid robot
to go out and navigate the entire rest
of the real world where there's an order
of magnitude more stuff to identify and
react to like I mean on the streets
there's obviously other cars and trucks
and buses and it can identify
motorcycles and bicycles and pedestrians
even and then there's traffic cones and
there's lights and all the rest of the
traffic control devices construction
zones arrows on the road just kind of
starting to run out that's almost it but
how well is the Tesla bot going to do
when you ask it to go get bananas from
the grocery store
like really like how good could it get
or if you ask it hey uh Tesla bot go
grab my airpods Max from downstairs
is it going to be able to know that
that's headphones or is it going to have
to have a model of every new pair of
headphones that ever comes out to be
able to identify which one you're
talking about and all of this training
that's you can see where I'm coming from
all this training has to come from Real
World data which I guess would have to
come from people using Tesla pots in
their homes and starting to get this
going which seems a little less likely
to me than people getting a self-driving
car and then there's just a whole bunch
of other unknowns about this robot too
uh what other colors will it come in
will it come in matte black how does it
charge will it just sit on a USB port in
the corner of a room every day I don't
know will this ever even go on sale
and I don't know if it's really even
about this robot going on sale as much
as it is just about honestly it could
really just be Tesla exploring their
computer vision in another form factor
just like Boston Dynamics it's just
about Tesla becoming the best AI and
computer vision company that they
possibly can and this being just one
more Avenue to get better at it so
there's no good reason I can think of
for a humanoid robot
to exist out there in people's hands
anyway uh but hey makes a lot of good
headlines
it's obviously something we've been
fascinated with forever and will
continue to be for a long time and it
could just be one more form factor that
Tesla's exploring
and also when have they ever said no to
a good free PR opportunity so anyway
that's about my thoughts on it I'm super
curious what you guys think if you have
any thoughts on would you want something
like this in your own home do you think
the robot will exist I'm sure the
comment section will be fun below this
one either way thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace